Okay. Um, we're not officially starting
yet, but uh, you know, people are
trickling in. I just want to show you a
little bit of what I will talk about
later on, which is uh, we have agents
inside of our Slack where let's say we
move the session from Wesley to more. I
just tell Devon to move it and it does
it and it's reflected on the website. Uh
so that's that's good fun. Um so this is
meant to be more of a unstructured Q&A
and also like if you have ideas to
improve um we had an open slot so I just
took the slot if you're interested in
how we run uh AI engineer if you have uh
complaints uh suggestions compliments
I'll take them all. Who wants to start
us off?
Yes, please.
>> Start start with
I still had 20 submissions and I only
had six spots. So
>> why why don't people have Slack? What
what what's going on in London?
>> You have Microsoft Teams?
>> Really?
>> Wow. Okay.
Yeah. Uh so the the the main thing was
we didn't want to uh publish it by
Twitter or something uh because
obviously we only want attendees to
access it. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Brain brain dump. Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Similarity search. Yep.
Okay.
>> So many people and you don't know how to
make
>> matching
conference at least I think we should
use all the latest
ideas
a lot. already.
>> Yeah.
I don't know.
>> I So yeah, the the the two cents is that
we did build that in 2024 and nobody
used it. Uh so I think it's it's uh it's
something where yes the technical
solution sounds simple but it's a
product that that is a social networking
tool that we are not specialist in in
that and we haven't really figured it
out. Uh I will say we publish all of our
data online. Uh we use Gemini embiddings
to the and uh you can you're welcome to
you know code your own apps and we'll
promote them if we see them. uh this
conference saw a lot less attendee vibe
coding apps and utilities for your own
use than in the US which is uh
interesting. I don't know what to say
about that apart from uh maybe uh we
didn't encourage it enough or something.
Um but yeah networking I I think what we
have the highest leverage on for
networking. Yes, I I I do agree we can
do a lot better there and I I don't love
uh what we do. I I I I think what we do
is okay is is what it's what everyone
does. Um what I tend to tell people is
if you're interested in a topic, you you
come to a a talk, a track, you know,
anyone interested in voice and and
vision was in that track and then you
stick around and talk to everyone in
that room because it's a self- selection
process of uh gathering. Um we will have
that we have more space for that in San
Francisco. But we just didn't have that
room where there's literally an al cove
outside of every single room where
people just gather and they never even
go in to watch the talk because it's all
recorded. Uh but you the the gathering
points are the the the tracks. Um we
also hosted a leadership lunch where
people were able some of you were there
you enjoyed it. Yeah. Um so obviously
leadership we had a attractor state and
I think we just kind of create more
events where people just attract uh uh
to to a particular topic that they care
about. Um, the other thing we also try
to do is we encourage our sponsors and
partners to host events and dinners on
their own. So, yesterday night was the
everyone just host your own thing night
and so you're supposed to meet people
there.
Uh,
yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We just improve. Yeah. Um, I
mean the truth is human connection is
hard and top down people resist it.
people like organic just serendipity and
we just create opportunities for that.
Um there is a form of conference where
there are no speakers which is fantastic
for me. I don't have a job. Um but the
the the entire job is to network you
with other people, right? So uh someday
we will do that kind of conference and
try but then the the the worry is people
don't show up because we're un like
people understand how to pay for a
conference where there are speakers you
want to see. people don't understand how
to pay for a conference where the point
is to meet the other people.
Um, just to give you an idea, you know,
we spend roughly uh, let's call it the
average ticket here is between a,000
to,500 pounds, maybe a bit more if you
were late. Um, we spend probably upwards
of two to 2.2,000 per attendee. How much
do you and and so uh the the question is
how if you if you if you have to drop
what you charge per ticket, how much how
do you make up uh the the sort of the
rest of the cost? Um so we haven't
really figured that out yet.
>> Slido. Yeah. Uh my my two cents is that
it's not that important. Slido is just a
kicking off point for the moderator to
pick the question they were already
going to pick anyway. Uh the main the
main thing I the main reason I
introduced slido was to avoid people
coming up to the mic and then telling
their telling you their life story which
happens all the time.
>> You like the life story.
>> It happens. It's too uncontrolled for
the tight schedules that we run on. We
run on very very tight schedules. Uh who
else?
Really?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh
>> yeah. So, so one you like the fireside
chess, you want more uh just generally.
Do you want more fireside chance? You
want you want you're okay with the
current level? Two hands, three hands.
Okay. maybe 20%. Um, yeah, I I'm I think
there are other conferences that are 90%
fireside chats. We want to be exact
opposite of that. Um, and uh that's
that's a choice. Um, I I find it high
higher signal if people do the homework
first instead of just spew whatever
comes out of their mouth. Uh, as like
I'm doing right now. Uh, uh, okay. The
Oh, sorry. What's the second one again?
The meet the speaker. Um we did that in
in one of the conferences that we did.
Um and uh basically we had an allocated
area where uh people could go a speaker
would be um they're not there like the
the the very popular ones there would be
a lot. It's very skewed. The very
popular ones there'll be a lot. The less
popular ones that be nobody. It's it's
very hard to manage. Um I think we could
have done better. I it's it's um I've
been to other conferences where I was
the speaker and and I uh stood around
and I got I got some mileage out of it.
I I think the the the problem I have
with it is that it is not a good use of
the speaker's time really. Uh it is just
a benefit for the attendee because
usually these things are unrecorded.
They're they're set to five people. Um
and I much rather have a public AMA
where it's 300 people and it's recorded
because that scales to the 10,000 people
that uh tuned in on the live stream
yesterday.
Yeah.
>> Lovely.
Uh before you came in, we had a question
on that one already. But uh I mean the
the simple answer is yes. Uh somebody is
going to solve it, but we're we are a
conference company and it's pro we're
probably not going to be the geniuses
that solve it. Uh I I I do I did try to
get something together, but it didn't
come together in time for this
conference. Uh I I was going to offer
everyone their own personal claw thing,
but I I don't think it would I I think
it would be kind of gimmicky. I think
50% of people already have their own
claws, so what's what's the point of us
offering a conference one? I don't know.
Um yeah.
>> Uh
Yeah. So, um uh the uh uh a lot of them
already are we actually um sort of
spread them out in order to respect the
YouTube algorithm. Um so if you go to
Oh, I should just mirror, right? Um
okay, forget it. Um if you go to the
YouTube uh and look at the playlist, the
unpublished videos are already up.
Yeah, we just we just drip it out over
time to try to maximize the algorithm.
Um because my job is to get every
speaker as much views as possible. Uh
it's good for us, it's good for them. Uh
but you can actually see it and we're uh
for the because of what happened on
Wednesday, uh we're actually going to
send every attendee an email with and
we're rushing the edits for the
workshops. So you get the workshops
Monday.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
no
to uh so the question is is there a
world where we live stream all the
workshops or all the tracks uh so here
we had six simultaneous tracks and I
think six six simultaneous workshops and
the simple answer is no uh there's uh
the expense of live streaming uh doesn't
decreases the the online views of of
each individual workshops um and the and
people want to edit want us to edit the
workshops anyway
So, uh really you gain a few days, maybe
a couple weeks worth of immediacy, but
you you sacrifice so much in terms of uh
money, quality, view, experience,
whatever. Uh
yeah, I think the max we've ever done is
four simultaneous and even that was too
much. Um two was two is good. Yeah,
YouTube just doesn't like it when you
spam so much at once. And we we really
spam a lot, right? We have 150 sessions
coming out of this one. If we posted one
a day, that's like half the year. Um, so
we have to spam and YouTube doesn't like
it and it does penalize us, but we just
do it anyway, right? Yeah.
>> Yes.
Thank you. I for for those who don't
know, I hate Spotify. Uh so I like it
when people listen to the
>> OG.
>> Yeah.
>> So you want you want you want the talks
as a podcast.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> It is. Uh yeah. Um we embed it in the UR
in the description. You're supposed to
be able to click it in the description.
Uh if it doesn't work, it doesn't work
either.
Um
yeah, the
YouTube will be the future. So we're
we're moving definitely moving moving
towards YouTube being the primary and
the audio being the mirror of the
YouTube. Um
>> I get it. I get you. I get you. Uh
anyway, so so that's lat space AIE. We
actually published uh the main uh feed
as a podcast. So, there is an RSS feed
you can plug in uh to to listen to
because people have asked for it and
YouTube does support it. Um yeah, I mean
I'm just not going to promote it very
much, but it's there if you look for it.
Again, go to the playlist page. Um the
the one that's like the complete list of
everything. That's the one that's going
to be the podcast version uh with the
RSS.
That's the kind of question.
>> Yeah. Uh yeah. So the question yeah the
question is how do we think about
audience over time? I'm uh before I bias
you with my answer what do you think it
is?
>> Yeah.
Uh okay. Um
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Um, so, so,
uh, well, it's in the name, right? If
you put engineer in the name, you can't
really stray that far. Um, the, yeah,
that's going broad versus going going,
uh, staying niche. Um, I think it's
something that I stress out a lot about.
Um I think the the uh that's why I think
putting AI engineer getting that domain
uh doing all everything that we did in
2023 was setting us up for constraints
that limit us from going wandering too
far off. Um we do have ambitions to grow
of course um and uh basically the the
way uh I I wrote this up in a in a essay
that that I call scaling uh without
slop. Um so if you if you want you can
go into latent space um
and go and this is the this is our
entire 20 2026 playbook um that you can
you can see here as well. Um so I
published uh a talk about what we're
doing as well as the uh the slope of
what we are we're trying to accomplish
uh the AI engineer plan and the latent
space plan. So it's all it's all in here
in long form if you want. Uh the TLDDR
is that we have different formats of the
Ag engineer concept. Uh the world's fair
will be the one that scales for breath
and the summits are the ones that go
deep. Um this one is a blend of them. Uh
what we're eventually evolving towards
is that every continent will have one
large multitrack generalist thing and
then the summits will be very focused
topic uh focused ones. The code one just
code. uh uh the next one will be on data
where uh people are buying and selling
data sets um or RL environments um and
we'll probably the one after that will
be voice um so which it's just what do
we think the right the time is right to
focus on something but they're all
centered on the engineer um and I think
niche the concept of a niche is sort of
fractal like what is niche to you may be
general to others because you can get
you can always niche down even more and
it just seems like you like the
technical content and that is a a strong
opinion that we have against um the
other conferences that may have happened
here or in Paris or even back home in
San Francisco.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So the question uh question is can
we please add five minutes to travel
time between the sessions? Um we uh
would I would love to but that does
sacrifice content. Um
I don't have an answer yet apart from so
far we have we I think we've done it
occasionally
um and it's not been great as compared
to just stuffing more more value in um
you know again again the um maybe I'll
finish my thought and then I I'll let
you respond. Um the idea is that you are
never going to see all the talks you
want to anyway. It's but we also spend a
lot on recording and we're going to
publish it and and post it up online.
And really this the the tracks are meant
to just bring together people all
interested in the same topic and you
could just stand outside the door and
get the 90% of the value. So really do I
care that you that everyone has the the
the the sufficient time to run from this
room down to the other room that they
really want to see? No. I don't know if
it's like the most important thing. And
keep in mind like some people end early.
It's just impossible logistically to uh
to do that. Um I do think like uh a more
relaxed conference uh like the ones so
our summits are single track. Uh meaning
there's nowhere to run. There's only one
thing going on at any one one time. Uh
but that then becomes extremely curated,
extremely focused and small. Uh by
comparison, we can only do so many of
those. Um th this sort of farm of things
and buffet of things seems to work most
scalably because people can chart their
own paths and uh it maybe leaves
everyone slightly more dissatisfied
compared to if something was organized
only for them completely matching their
interests. Uh but it is it is a is a
nice enough sort of ven diagram of
everybody that like I can I can sort of
be happy choosing that. Uh but yeah, I
mean the simple answer is that uh I
think everyone would be more happy if we
only if we did more summits. Uh my team
just doesn't have the capability to put
on more. Um but it sounds like you would
be happy with that because there's
nowhere to travel. You just go in and
out of the talk space.
We uh Okay. So um so the the the your
your your idea is that you could run
some of the talks over lunchtime and
people can just eat during the lunch or
whatever. Uh the this is a sponsor
thing. Um so we actually want to treat
the sponsors well. We want to give
people space to mingle. Um and if we
always have content running at all
times. Uh there's there's never any
clear place to or to like shepherd
people through uh the sponsor booths um
who have nice swag and like people want
to talk to you and all that. Um, yeah,
that's just a trade-off that we've made.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. So, so this is a this is a
Have you done a workshop before? Have
you have you taught
Huh?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh, so um
I don't know that I have the right
answer to this one. Uh so this this is
this is a thing that um I I know is
suboptimal but I let it happen which is
that effectively workshops are very long
talks and lectures and and some people
valiantly try to follow along and and
and then and then they tune out as as as
you discovered uh at the end of the day
I have made peace with it because again
it's all recorded and if you miss
something or you fell behind on
something you can go online and watch
the playback and follow along at home
where you can hit the pause button,
right? Um, so I I do optimize for just
density of content and information and
people do like that and if you want to
pause, spread it out, talk to them
afterwards, you can do that as well. Um,
because obviously the the workshop
instructors tend to stick around
afterwards. Um
yeah I I think and it's funny that that
people don't get this question at the
academic conferences like our peers at
new rips and ICML and I clear uh
workshops are are actually less hands-on
and more just just lectures and I think
that's okay. Um I don't really know how
to feel about the uh that what we
recommend. Um I tell people it should be
5050 hands-on versus lecture. uh and
they all gravitate towards lecture. Um
so I think that's okay. I I I mean
feel free to suggest if you've you've
experienced better in other conferences.
Yeah.
Yes, exactly like this recording is
going to be. Uh so
>> yes, yeah, yeah, you you just need media
training of like, hey, remember that the
uh the microphones don't pick up the the
audience question. Um,
I think again I think this is one of
those things where
we only get the speakers we get who work
in the field and have this valuable
information who are not trying to sell
you their course because uh they they
they have this day job. I mean a lot of
them are paid to to talk to you but like
um you know some of these people are not
professional instructors at all. Um but
you you get things from them that you
wouldn't get elsewhere. I think that's
pretty valuable. I think if you wanted a
very fully well-produced polished
course, you could go pay for that
online. Um, here you are meeting the
practitioners who do the thing. And I
think uh to me that dominates uh the
imperfections of they are inexperienced
at holding the mic close to their mouse
or repeating the question or anything of
that sort. For example, I've been
instructed to stay here near near to the
podium because so I can stay within the
camera range. um people forget and it's
like I do a podcast and I interview
people and they they turn away from
their mic and it's very frustrating. But
look at the end of the day I'd rather
have them with flaws than not have them
at all. Um
they could they could the volunteers
also need training then it's just
and and uh and and and then they they
forget to um Yeah.
We can like again like um I I do I do
think there's a 8020 here of uh we do
like roughly what is enough to for for
people to get the gist and get get the
education. Could it be a lot more could
it could we spend expend lot more effort
to get to the 100% quality? Yes. But it
probably costs too much for the the the
comparative alpha that we gain from
that. Um uh that's it. I I think I I
think I like what you're saying and I
think we can do more workshop training.
I've always wanted to do that. Uh in
terms of like the people that do teach
our workshops, we I give them a little
write up. Um probably we can host
moreformational sessions and uh educate
them on what what what we want. We do
this for sponsors. We don't do this for
speakers. And we probably should.
No, I appreciate that. And this is this
is that's what this is for. Um yeah. Uh
yeah, I you know I
Sometimes I'm even conflicted on having
workshops at all. Right? Those are the
things I I that they're keeping me up at
night where well we spend so much effort
and time and move the chairs around and
the schedule's all all crazy and maybe
we don't need it. Maybe maybe we just do
talks. Yeah.
Okay.
You need a change log.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
We uh so so okay the the the the first
one was um
clear. Okay. Yeah. So, uh yes, we could
do that, but also at this point we are
kind of banking on our reput our past
work. Uh uh just like I prominently link
the YouTube in every single thing we we
send out and do and you can see on the
YouTube that it's there's this history
but yes, you can do that. Um the second
one uh is is is a more operational
thing. We uh have done that before um uh
in terms of notifying people of changes.
It used to be more Slack. Slack just
didn't Nobody's I I could tell that
there like 25 people signed up for Slack
this time out of the
>> I I know. I know. I know. We just We
just We're very suspect about using it.
It is a new vendor for us. We could have
used it more. Um uh the the truth is
just we are all too stretched thin to
really think through that and we
probably could do better next time. So
yeah, I think we could do better. um
you know and some some changes are very
minor like I pushed everyone back 10
minutes today something like that uh
some very major uh where for example
Armen uh was supposed to speak this this
afternoon we moved him to uh the morning
and we made that decision at 8:30 that
he would go on in 9:30 and um we would
have had to notify everyone but also
I think it just mattered that he showed
up
So um yeah I I yes in an ideal
experience that is exactly what we
should do and uh we yeah you know
feedback taken I think we can do that.
>> We have an attendee guide that went on
Monday.
>> Yeah.
Okay.
>> Yep.
>> It is on the schedule that there are
food blocks and there are afterparty
blocks, but yes, we can we can do a
better job of informing that. Uh these
these are the kinds of things by the way
where um we spend money on a thing, we
allocate time for a thing and people
don't know don't know about it so we
don't get any credit for doing it and
it's like wow that's frustrating. We
should we should get some credit for
like you know spending whatever we we
did on food.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean we got fabric for after for the
after party and that's like 50k and like
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yes. She's the general manager.
>> Yeah.
I see. I see. It's just a gathering is
all you want. Um, so the associates aka
volunteers are that uh we have a lot of
people currently going through uh
university who would be the younger crew
there. Maybe you're a recent grad. Um,
yes, we could do that. Uh in fact I had
a request from a sponsor today that in
Worlds Fair we do something for the uh
13 to 17 year olds very young. Yeah
because he has he's a young he's a
father and he's also thinking about how
do we get our kids involved anyway. Um
the very brutal honest truth is that
this conference is not designed for you.
Uh it is we once senior uh we we we get
advantage from being regarded as the one
that the the best engineers go to. Um
and and we trust that you are
intelligent enough to figure things out
yourself. Uh that's it. If it's if all
it takes is one meetup where say people
who are new to conferences gather here,
make friends, of course we can do that
and we should do that. Um and uh so so
yeah, but but uh we we do have a lot of
we target more senior.
>> Yeah. Um okay, maybe I'll prompt because
I think you all you guys are coming. um
curation, pricing, dates, location.
Any feedback on that?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Vendor pitches. Yes.
>> Okay.
uh but you still feel that most of the
talks are valuable to you. Okay.
>> To me that's acceptable. You know I
cannot um some people are going to just
get on stage and do their thing. Some
like uh my favorite quote about
advertising is that people watch what
entertains them and sometimes it's an
ad. You know what I mean? Like it just
matters whether they did it well or not.
Like you know in in in the US like the
Super Bowl like people only tune in for
the ads. um because it's entertaining
like I you know but and and I think so I
think that the lesson from that is uh
just try to pick good speakers and some
of them will get through my filters and
be not as good and trust me I hear about
them and they won't come back
um so uh that feedback is taken um I
take extreme notice of every speaker
that I that I pick um and uh there's
some selection process there there. But
yeah, I think it's understood it. Yeah,
we we cannot screen that much and people
change their content a lot. Uh and
sometimes they're just going to show
sometimes there will be good shows in
which you in which case you don't care,
don't notice, and sometimes they'll be
bad. Um um I I think like what's what's
funny is that one man's poison is
another man's anti- poison or whatever.
Uh in in the sense that like I have had
complaints and compliments about the
same talk, right? where like hey I
really like using this thing and the guy
is from that company and he came and did
did his job on that company and this is
something I always wanted to to go deep
on whereas the other person who had no
interest whatsoever complains that this
is a shill talk right uh well then just
don't sit there you know like um this is
one of those things where like to manage
this thing at scale and uh cater to a
very wide
levels of taste and familiarity and
preferences is uh we have to be accept
accepting of some slip slippage um
because we actually don't even know if
that was good.
Um case in point, one of the speakers
that that have had complaints about
today uh was the best performing speaker
last time. How was I supposed to know?
Yeah. Okay. Uh one more question if any.
Uh again I'm looking for feedback on
curation, venue, location. Uh venue and
location are the same thing. Uh timing
maybe in to come back in London. We are
going to come back next year, you know.
And uh anything like that pricing
>> nice.
>> Yeah. Would would uh I think our late
bird pricing is something like 1,800
pounds. Is that too high?
>> But because like everyone buys last
minute, right? Like you are rare enough
that you did need a super early bird. Um
but what what are we supposed to do?
>> Yeah. No, no. I mean, okay, you know,
and I actually want to be in a position
where like look like we're, you know,
again, we lose money on every every uh
ticket and then we have to make it up in
sponsors. Um there are other conferences
out there that are no sponsors purely uh
attendee funded and they are four times
five times what we charge. Should we do
that? What does that look like? Do to me
I don't even want to worry about $100
$200 differences or pound differences. I
I want to think about what are the very
big shifts that I can make as CEO that
then change the culture, the the the
sort of positioning, the expectation or
whatever. I don't know.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Everyone's pointing pointing me to
Excel and not being very excited about
it, which uh means to me that we
probably shouldn't choose it. Uh, I've
been told to try for the British Museum.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And is that good or bad?
>> Okay.
Oh, you're not based in London.
>> You're You're not based in London. You
have to
Okay. Okay. Okay. Hotels are expensive.
Um, you did not have to stay with so
close, I guess. But yeah. Okay. Okay.
So, so timing. Yeah. So, so, so yeah,
we're we're literally like, you know,
two days after Easter or something,
right? Um, yes. And and multiple British
people told me about that. Um, but hey,
you're supposed to be back at work. I
don't know. Uh, so again, like again,
this this is maybe like a school problem
and we're not we're not catered to that
as the primary audience. Um, uh,
understood. Um, we could we could host
in a in a cheaper venue. Um, and I I
think I think yes, I think I think I
think that actually does make sense for
London. In San Francisco and in New
York, we really really do try to be in
the heart of the city uh because that
makes it easy for our VIPs to come. Um,
and that and that drives everything
else. Whereas here, I feel like if we
were closer to King's Cross, where where
Deep Mine is, no one would mind and we
probably should have done that.
Um, okay. Well, I'll wrap it up there.
If you have any other questions, just
email them or tweet at me. Thank you so
much for coming.